you're both mostly in agreement but what
is I don't know if i' say that okay but
as I'm learning uh what is Israel doing
right what is Israel doing wrong in this
very specific current war in
Gaza um I mean frankly I think that what
Israel is doing wrong is if I were
Israel okay like again America's
interests are not coincident with
Israel's interest if if if I were an
Israeli leader I would have swiveled up
and and knocked the leap out ofah early
does does mean so I I would have I would
y Galant who was the defense minister of
Israel was encouraging Netanyahu is the
prime minister and the war cabinet
including Benny Gan so whenever people
talk about the Netanyahu government
that's not what's in place right now
there's a Unity War government in place
that includes the political opposition
the reason I point that out is because
there are a lot of people politically
who will suggest that the actions Israel
is currently taking are somehow the
manifestation of a right-wing government
Israel currently does not have a
quotequote right-wing government they
have Unity government that includes the
opposition in any case yov Galant was
urging in the very early days of the war
that Israel should turn north and
instead of hitting Hamas they should
actually take the opportunity to knock
hisbah out because hisbah is
significantly more dangerous to the
existence of the state of Israel than
Hamas I actually agree with that uh as
far as what Israel has been doing wrong
in the actual War I mean I think
that again from an American perspective
I think that Israel is is doing pretty
well from an Israeli perspective V
Israeli I would actually want Israel to
be less loose about sending
its soldiers in on the ground level so
Israel's attempting to minimize civilian
casualties and the cost of that has been
the highest military death toll that
Israel has had since the 1973 yum kipur
War I mean I personally know through one
degree of separation three separate
people have been killed in Gaza and
that's because they're going in door
Todo it's because they're they're
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties and they're losing a lot of
guys in in this particular in this
particular War um you know the the the
problem that Israel has had historically
speaking is that Israel got very
complacent about its own security
situation they belied the technology was
going to somehow correct for the hatred
on the other side of the wall that very
okay so are people have to live
underground for two weeks at a time
while some Rockets fall but at least
it's not a war and that complacence you
know bred what happened on October 7th
so to to me what Israel did wrong was
years and years and years of complacence
and belief in an Oslo system that is at
root a failure because you cannot make a
peace agreement with people who do not
want make peace with you so that that
that's what I think isra doing wrong I I
have a feeling there's going to be wide
Divergence on this point um maybe uh so
uh in terms of broadly speaking um I
generally oppose settlement expansion is
a thing that Israel does incorrectly
that I think is kind of like provocative
to at least all the Palestinians uh in
the West Bank and I probably energize
his hatred in the Gaza trip for them as
well in terms of conducting uh in terms
of conducting Warfare uh the one thing
that I always say to everybody uh
especially Americans is you can't
evaluate things from an American
perspective it's very stupid happened a
lot with Ukraine where people like oh
well didn't they work with the Nazis and
like weren't the Soviets the good guys
and it's like well in other parts of the
world it's not quite as simple um and I
think the same is true for Israel
Palestine that a lot of Americans will
analyze the conflict as just being one
between only Israel and Palestine which
it's not it's a conct between Israel and
then Palestine heah the houthis and Iran
right now it is um I think that the
however one area where I'll break with
Ben is is I think that minimizing
civilian casualties and everything is
very very very important I think on the
Israel side I don't think it's important
so that the US will stay with them
because I think the US is probably going
to stick with Israel as long as they
don't do anything crazy and I don't even
think it matters for the International
Community it doesn't definitely doesn't
matter for the UN because Jesus Christ
um however I think it's really really
really important that I think that in
the Middle East broadly speaking I think
that leadership especially in the Gulf
has gotten over the Palestinian uh issue
I think that leadership is kind of like
they don't care as much anymore but the
populations still care quite bit and I
think that the main issue that Israel
could run into is if the civilian death
toll does climb too high and if they
start to hit this you know 40 50 60,000
number of Civilian casualties they run
the risk of the civilian populations and
the surrounding middle eastern states
becoming so antagonistic towards Israel
that they start to take steps back
towards normalization in the region so
for instance I know that um Bahrain I
think already pulled out their
Ambassador um to Israel my guess is
going to be it's temporary um I know
that on the um on the public side you've
got a lot of people condemning Israel
for the attacks and on the private side
you've got people telling Israel please
kill all of Hamas because this is
untenable and nobody wants to work in
the situation um I don't know if this
ended up being true or not I'm guessing
it didn't but I saw on a couple of
Twitter accounts it was leaked that
potentially Saudi Arabia was considering
installing a government in the West Bank
that they would run um no I mean I I
think Israel would love nothing better
than that but that is something one of
the big problems in the Middle East is
literally no one wants to preside over
the Palestinians no one Arab states
Israel no one so I think the issue is
and I think and I'm largely actually I'm
very sympathetic towards the
Palestinians because I think that for um
since 48 and onwards I think that all of
the Arab states super gassed them up on
that they wanted the Palestinians to
fight because they wanted to fight with
Israel um however as time has gone on
and they' realized that the it's kind of
a lost cause states have started to drop
out so you're getting these bilateral uh
peace treaties with um Egypt and with
Jordan you're getting multilateral
agreements like the Abraham Accords and
now the Palestinians are looking around
and like okay guys told us to fight all
this time and now the only people that
we have supporting us are Iranian
proxies um so the Palestinians are in a
very weird spot where they've like lost
all their support um yeah I think that I
think that Israel what I would say to be
quote unquote critical of Israel is
Israel needs to take strong steps
towards peace that probably involves
them enduring some undue hardship so not
the October 7th attacks because Jesus
that's way too much but you know other
types of you know attacks that they
might have to deal with that might cause
some civilians to die that they don't
come out over the top with and and
retaliate with if there's ever going to
be peace in that region however another
thing that I've always said is a huge
problem between Israel and palestin is I
think that both sides think that if they
continue to fight it will be good for
them but the problem is one side is
delusional uh Israel I think Israel
wants to continue to fight because they
get justifications for uh the annexation
of the Golan Heights they get
justifications for expansions especially
in area SE that I that think they're
probably going to try to Annex soon uh
they get justifications for the
increased military posturing uh towards
the Gaza Strip and the embargos and
Israel is right that if the conflict
continues really the situation only
improves for Israel Over time but the
Palestinians also all believe that if
they keep fighting they thought this
since 2000 under Arafat that if they
just keep fighting they'll get better
gains too but that's not the case is
there a difference between Palestinian
citizens and the leadership when you say
that I love all people I love all people
around the world and I think that when
we analyze issues I think that we have
to be very honest with what the people
on the ground think and the idea that
Hamas is just this one off thing in the
Gaza Strip is not only incorrect with
the situation on the ground it's also
incredibly ahistorical um and the idea
that like the Palestinians in the West
Bank of which I believe the most recent
polling shows I want to say 75 to 80%
support the October 7th attacks um
Palestinians in general want to fight in
violent conflict with Israel that's not
just the position of the government
that's not just people there's a reason
why a boss doesn't want to do uh
elections in the West Bank uh and it's
because the Palestinian people really do
want to fight with is but to combat that
problem is like you have to get the UN
on board we've got to do an actual
addressing of the Palestinian refugee
problem which is handled like a joke
right now um Iran has to be brought to
the table in terms of negotiations uh
there has to be huge efforts made to
economically Revitalize these like
Palestinian areas even though they're
one of the highest recipients of Aid in
the world um you you have to do
something about the Embargo and the
blockade and the Gaza Strip which isn't
just maintained by Israel it's also
maintained by Egypt you should ask why
um yeah there's a lot of things that
have to happen to fix that problem but
the reality is is I don't think Israel
really wants to because they get to
continue their expansion into the West
Bank and I don't think anybody around
the world really cares that much month
we won't be talking I will argue with
that the idea that Israel does not want
to end the conflict is be lied by the
history of what just happened with the
Gaza Strip so when we talk about
settlements for example Israel did have
settlements inside the Gaza Strip there
were 8,000 Jews who were living inside
the Gaza Strip in gush katif uh up until
2005 they they they withdrew all of
those people I mean took them literally
out of their homes uh and the result was
not the burgeoning of a of a better
attitude toward the state of Israel with
regard to for example you know the the
Palestinian population in Gaza in fact
it was more radical in Gaza than it was
in the West Bank uh the the the result
was obviously the election of Kamas the
the October 7th attacks in which
unfortunately many civilians took place
took part in the October 7th attacks
there's video of people rushing who are
civilians and dressed in civilian
clothing into Israeli villagers not
always the same thing oh no no that is
that is 100% true obviously uh and when
it comes to you know know area C and
Israel's you know supposed deep and
abiding desire for territorial expansion
in area C area C so for for those who
are not familiar with the oo cords and
again this is getting very abstruse but
the oso cords are broken down into three
areas of the West Bank area a is under
full Palestinian control that would be
like Janine and Nablus the the major
cities for example there's area B which
is mixed Israeli Palestinian control
where Israel provides some level of
military security and control uh and
then there's area C and area C was like
to be decided later it was left up for
Poss
concessions to the Palestinian Authority
if the a Accords had moved forward those
are disputed territories there is
building taking place in areas by both
actually no one talks about this but by
by Palestinians as well as Israelis uh
and the the you know question is to
whether if Israel stop building there
have been many settlement freees in the
past including some undertaken by
Netanyahu uh and and it actually has not
done one iota of good in moving the ball
forward in terms of actual negotiations
again the the biggest problem is that
the leadership for Palestinians has
spent every day since really 67 it's not
even 48 because after 40 between 48 and
67 Jordan was in charge of the West Bank
and Egypt was in charge of the Gaza
Strip and no point did either of those
Powers say hey maybe we ought to hand
this over to an independent Palestinian
state which was originally the division
that was that was promoted by the UN
partition plan in
47 because of that uh the the leadership
post 67 and really starting in 64 the
Palestine Liberation Organization was
founded in ' 64 and it called for the
liberation of the land in ' 64 they had
the West Bank and they had the Gaza
Strip so they're talking about Tel Aviv
uh when it was founded in in ' 64 the
basic idea as you know kind of indicated
by that was Israel will not exist and
that was a promise that's been made by
pretty much every Palestinian leader in
Arabic to the people that they are
talking to yasat famously would do this
sort of thing he'd speak in English and
talk about how he wanted a two-state
solution and then he'd go back to his
own people and say this is a trojan
horse and we're if Israel could if you
think that Israeli parents want to send
their kids at the age of 18 to go and
monitor Janine and Nablus and be in inun
you're out of your mind you're out of
your mind Israelis do not want that in
fact Israelis didn't want that so much
that they allowed Rockets to fall in
their cities for full on 18 years in
order to avoid sending soldiers on mass
back into the Gaza Strip true but I
think Israel does want to continue to
expand settlements into the West Bank
right they want to continue to build
they want to have Jerusalem East
Jerusalem as well well I mean East
Jerusalem has already been annexed so
East Jerusalem is according to Israel a
part of Israel that's not a settlement
Okay so there's that with regard to you
know does Israel have an interest in
expanding settlements in the West Bank
why would they not until there's a peace
partner sure that's what I mean but I'm
saying as long as the conflict continues
like because even when you talk about no
but your suggestion is that they're
incentivizing the conflict to continue
so they can grab more land well no let
me be very clear I don't think there's
like a PL like so some people say for
instance uh they'll take that one quote
from Netanyahu and they'll try to say
that like he was funding the people in
the Gaza Strip by allowing katari money
to come in even though he was actually
speaking in opposition to a boss
allowing the gusa strip to fall for
Netanyahu to clear it out for him they
give it back etc etc I'm not saying I'm
not claiming those theories I'm just
saying that I think that Israel will
take a relatively neutral stance towards
conflict in enduring because as long as
the conflict endures and as long as the
uh settlements can expand I think that
benefits I think that ultimately
benefits Israel the I think there would
be very let's put this way if suddenly
there arose among the Palestinians a
deep and abiding desire for peace
approved by a vast majority of the
population with serious security
guarantees I think you'd be very
hardpressed to find Israelis who would
not be willing to at least consider that
in not expanding bathrooms in a fra I
kind of I would have agreed with you on
October 6 I think we're probably a year
or two away from that right now no no
but no the point I'm making is that
Israelis now realized that the entire
peace process was a sham meaning the
people who are on the other side of the
table were using it as a trojan horse in
the first place that the death of Oslo
is not the death of Israeli hopefulness
it's the death of the illusion that on
the other side of the table was anyone
worth bargaining with that's what's
happening and that's why you have this
sort of insane disconnect right now
between the United States and the
Israeli government again it's a Unity
government no one in Israel is talking
talking about making concessions to the
Palestinian Authority for a wide variety
of reasons including the fact that
Mahmud abas fat continues to pay actual
families of terrorists who kill Jews the
mar fund yeah right and and which is
from the the moderate West Bank right
exactly that's that so you again like
the taste in Israel for this is a even
the people who are the the kilon right
those are the most secular people in
Israel which was by the way the place
that was attacked on October 7th I mean
what people should understand is that
October 7th was not an attack against
settlements in the West Bank it was an
attack on peace Villages that were
essentially disarmed and many of these
people who were killed were peace
activists who were literally trying to
work with people in Gaza to get them I
mean it's just it's it's mind-boggling
that's why you've had this ground shift
in Israel the next 20 years in Israel is
going to be about security and economic
development period end of story
everything else goes second third place
and I will say I agree essentially with
everything you're saying um not to loop
back on another topic but this is one of
the reasons then why I was so critical I
don't want to say critical but like kind
of nonchalant about the Abraham Accords
because they didn't address anything
with the Palestinians whatsoever they
brought countries that weren't super
relevant the conflict they didn't bring
in Qatar which is where a lot of the
money and support for the god con they
didn't involve Iran at all they involved
bilateral but it totally changed the
mentality and this is why what I'm
seeing right now this is why listen I
think that that Biden has done better
than I certainly expected him to do in
terms of support for Israel like Obama
was way less supportive of Israel than
Biden by every metric with that said the
rhetoric that he's been using recently
and the blankin have been using recently
about Israel needs to make painful
concessions for peace Israel reentering
this issue at the center of relations in
the Middle East is doomed to failure the
magic magic is a strong word the the
benefit of the Abraham Accords was proof
of what you're saying which is true
which is that all the surrounding
countries in reality have abandoned the
idea that there's a centrality to the
Palestinian Israeli conflict that is not
the central conflict in the Middle East
and by the way one of the reasons it's
not the central conflict in the Middle
East is because actually ironically
because of the rise of Iran right it's
it's Sunni states that are largely
signing up with Israel because they're
realizing they need some sort of
counterweight to a a burgeoning nuclear
power in
Iran